Last week, I put up this video about solving
the game Wordle, or at least trying to solve
it, using information theory, and I wanted
to add a quick...what should we call this?
An addendum?
A confession?
Basically, I just want to explain a place
where I made a mistake.
It turns out there was a very slight bug in
the code that I was running to recreate Wordle
and then run all of the algorithms to solve
it and test their performance.
It's one of those bugs that affect a very
small percentage of cases, so it was easy
to miss, and it has only a very slight effect
that, for the most part, doesn't really matter.
Basically, it had to do with how you assign
a color to a guess that has multiple different
letters in it.
For example, if you guess "speed" and the
true answer is "abide", how should you color
those two E's from the guess?
Well, the way that it works with the Wordle
conventions is that the first e would be colored
yellow, and the second one would be colored
gray.
You might think of that first one as matching
up with something from the true answer, and
the grayness is telling you there is no second
e.
By contrast, if the answer was something like
"erase", both of those e's would be colored
yellow, telling you that there is a first
e in a different location, and there's a second
e also in a different location.
Similarly, if one of the e's hits and it's
green, then that second one would be gray
in the case where the true answer has no second
e, but it would be yellow in the case where
there is a second e, and it's just in a different
location.
Long story short, somewhere along the way,
I accidentally introduced behavior that differs
from these conventions slightly.
And honestly, it was really dumb.
Basically, at some point in the middle of
the project, I wanted to speed up some of
the computations, and I was trying a little
trick for how it computed the value for this
pattern between any given pair of words, and
I just didn't really think it through, and
it introduced this slight change.
The ironic part is that in the end, the actual
way to make things fastest is to precompute
all those patterns so that everything is just
a lookup.
So it wouldn't matter how long it takes to
do each one, especially if you're writing
hard-to-read buggy code to make it happen.
You live and you learn.
As far as how this affects the actual video,
I mean, very little of substance really changes.
Of course, the main lessons about what is
information, what is entropy, all that stays
the same.
Every now and then, if I'm showing on screen
some distribution associated with a given
word, that distribution might actually be
a little bit off, because some of the buckets
associated with various patterns should include
either more or fewer true answers.
Even then, it doesn't really come up, because
it was very rare that I would be showing a
word that had multiple letters that also hit
this edge case.
But one of the very few things of substance
that does change, and that arguably does matter
a fair bit, was the final conclusion around
how if we want to find the optimal possible
score for the Wordle answer list, what opening
guess does such an algorithm use?
In the video, I said the best performance
that I could find came from opening with the
word "crane", which was true only in the sense
that the algorithms were playing a very slightly
different game.
After fixing it and rerunning it all, there
is a different answer for what the theoretically
optimal first guess is for this particular
list.
And look, I know that you know that the point
of the video is not to find some technically
optimal answer to some random online game.
The point of the video is to shamelessly hop
on the bandwagon of an internet trend to sneak
attack people with an information theory lesson.
And that's all good, I stand by that part.
But I know how the Internet works, and for
a lot of people the one main takeaway was
what is the best opener for the game Wordle.
And I get it.
I walked into that because I put it in the
thumbnail.
But presumably you can forgive me if I want
to add a little correction here.
And a more meaningful reason to circle back
to all this, actually, is that I never really
talked about what went into that final analysis,
and it's interesting as a sub-lesson in its
own right, so that's worth doing here.
Now, if you'll recall, most of our time last
video was spent on the challenge of trying
to write an algorithm to solve Wordle that
did not use the official list of all possible
answers.
To my taste, that feels a bit like overfitting
to a test set.
And what's more fun is building something
that's resilient.
This is why we went through the whole process
of looking at relative word frequencies in
the English language to come up with some
notion of how likely each one would be to
be included as a final answer.
However, for what we're doing here, where
we're just trying to find an absolute best
performance, period, I am incorporating that
official list and just shamelessly overfitting
to the test set.
Which is to say we know with certainty whether
a word is included or not, and we can assign
a uniform probability to each one.
If you'll remember, the first step in all
of this was to say for a particular opening
guess, maybe something like my old favorite
"crane", how likely is it that you would see
each of the possible patterns?
And in this context where we are shamelessly
overfitting to the Wordle answer list, all
that involves is counting how many of the
possible answers give each one of these patterns.
And then, of course, most of our time was
spent on this kind of funny-looking formula
to quantify the amount of information that
you would get from this guest.
That basically involves going through each
one of those buckets and saying, how much
information would you gain that has this log
expression that is a fanciful way of saying,
how many times would you cut your space of
possibilities in half?
If you observed a given pattern, we take a
weighted average of all of those, and it gives
us a measure of how much we expect to learn
from this first guess.
In a moment, we'll go deeper than this.
But if you simply search through all 13,000
different words that you could start with
and you ask which one has the highest expected
information, it turns out the best possible
answer is "soare", which doesn't really look
like a real word, but I guess it's an obsolete
term for a baby Hawk.
The top 15 openers by this metric happen to
look like this.
But these are not necessarily the best opening
guesses, because they're only looking one
step in with a heuristic of expected information
to try to estimate what the true score will
be.
But there are few enough patterns that we
can do an exhaustive search two steps in.
For example, let's say you opened with "soare",
and the pattern you happen to see was the
most likely one all greys's.
Then you can run identical analysis from that
point for a given proposed second guess, something
like "kitty", what's the distribution across
all patterns in that restricted case where
we're restricted only to the words that would
produce all grays for "soare"?
And then we measure the flatness of that distribution
using this expected information formula, and
we do that for all 13,000 possible words that
we could use as a second guess.
Doing this, we can find the optimal second
guess in that scenario and the amount of information
we are expected to get from it.
And if we wash, rinse, and repeat and do this
for all of the different possible patterns
that you might see, we get a full map of all
the best possible second guesses, together
with the expected information of each from
there.
If you take a weighted average of all those
second step values, weighted according to
how likely you are to fall into that bucket,
it gives you a measure of how much information
you're likely to gain from the guest "soare"
after the second step.
When we use this two-step metric as our new
means of ranking the list gets shaken up a
bit.
"Soare" is no longer first place, it falls
back to 14th, and instead what rises to the
top is "slane".
Again, this doesn't feel very real, and it
looks like it is a British term for a spade
that's used for cutting turf.
All right.
But as you can see, it is a really tight race
among all of these top contenders for who
gains the most information after those two
steps.
And even still, these are not necessarily
the best opening guesses because information
is just the heuristic, it's not telling us
the actual score if you actually play the
game.
What I did is I ran the simulation of playing
all 2315 possible Wordle games with all possible
answers on the top 250 from this list.
And by doing this, seeing how they actually
perform, the one that ends up very marginally
with the best possible score turns out to
be "salet".
Which is... an alternate spelling for "Sallet",
which is a light medieval helmet.
All right, if that feels a little bit too
fake for you, which it does for me, you'll
be happy to know that "Trace" and "Crate"
give almost identical performance, and each
of them has the benefit of obviously being
a real word.
So there is one day when you get it right
on the first guess, since both are actual
Wordle answers.
This move from sorting based on the best two
step-entropy to sorting based on the lowest
average score also shakes up the list, but
not nearly as much.
For example, "Salet" was previously third
place before it bubbles to the top, and "Crate"
and "Trace" were both fourth and fifth.
If you're curious, you can get slightly better
performance from here by doing a little brute-forcing.
There's a very nice blog post by Jonathan
Olsen if you're curious about this, where
he also lets you explore what the optimal
following guesses are for a few of the starting
words based on these optimal algorithms.
Stepping back from all this, though, I'm told
by some people that it quote ruins the game
to overanalyze it like this and try to find
an optimal opening guess.
It feels kind of dirty if you use that opening
guess after learning it, and it feels inefficient
if you don't.
But the thing is, I don't actually think this
is the best opener for a human playing the
game.
For one thing, you would need to know what
the optimal second guess is for each one of
the patterns that you see.
And more importantly, all of this is in a
setting where we are absurdly overfit to the
official wordle answer list.
The moment that, say, the New York Times chooses
to change what that list is under the hood,
all of this would go out the window.
The way we humans play the game is just very
different from what any of these algorithms
are doing.
We don't have the word list memorized, we
aren't doing exhaustive searches.
We get intuition from things like "what are
the vowels" and "how are they placed"?
I would actually be most happy if those of
you watching this video promptly forgot what
happens to be the technically best opening
guess and instead came out remembering things
like how do you quantify information, or the
fact that you should look out for when a greedy
algorithm falls short of the globally best
performance that you would get from a deeper
search.
To my taste, at least, the joy of writing
algorithms to try to play games actually has
very little bearing on how I like to play
those games as a human.
The point of writing algorithms for all this
is not to affect the way you play the game,
it's still just a fun word game.
The point is to hone in our muscles for writing
algorithms in more meaningful contexts elsewhere.